So now, let's just talk to you about Indexes, and
how every query needs to have an Index. So let's see
what happens, if you deploy an application to app spot, that
requires a new index. So what we're going to do, is
update our Filter Playground Method. You may have called this method
something else, but this is the method where you've been adding
your hardwired filters. Anyway, we're going to update it to filter
for another thing. So for example, let's filter it for conferences
in June. So we just filter on month equals six, because
the month is recorded by an integer and six is June.
After you've added this filter, go ahead and deploy your application
directly to app spot. In this case, do not run the
query on local host first. I know I've been telling you
always run it on local host first, but now I want
you to see what happens if you don't. So, don't run
it on local host, just run it directly on app spot.
Try running your query in the API's explorer. What happens?